oh
[Music]
so since Halloween is coming up I
thought it would be fun to review and
rate
the offensiveness of some past celebrity
Halloween costumes okay oh nice that's
funny except this video is going to drop
like in January
start editing in the middle of this
video make it a Hot Topic yeah I got it
all right this one is Sean White as
simple Jack that's fine it's okay that's
okay what about who's next home I don't
know [ __ ] is that those are Kid Rock
dude the one on the one on the left is
more offensive than the one really right
what would you say that because he looks
like he looks weird
it looks weird we don't like that simple
Jack that's pretty good though to do a
deep cut character from a movie that's a
parody about
uh blackface and Brown face and [ __ ] I
think it's pretty fun right it's like
layers yeah layers away right Simple
Jack so that one's now it's like a one
huh yeah no that's not that bad how
about this Kate Hudson as the Wild Child
country cult do you know them what's the
deal with them it's the um the bhagwan
Shri ran rajnish there they did like
bioterrorism in uh Oregon with
salmonella oh God I got like seven like
hundreds of people got sick that's right
oh wasn't that a movie about that yeah
there's a docu series yeah how come they
don't get enough shine how come Dahmer's
getting all the shine but they're not I
mean it was a huge documentary document
series when it came out like three years
ago but then Dahmer has like 15 [ __ ]
documentaries that's on Netflix yeah but
that's because he's so cool
is this mid I think that's not offensive
at all okay I I think it's hilarious I
wouldn't have guessed a bunch of whites
got convinced to do evil things by an
Indian man yeah
[Music]
see the hair's a little much huh yeah
that's a lot I think this one's pretty
[ __ ] because Diana Ross never had this
hair yeah bro like what is this oh
that's weird what is that she's uh she
she's the what's it called Real
Housewife or something yeah yeah okay
oh so now you now it's okay it's okay
you're a fan huh it depends what what uh
what area is Orange County if it's
Orange County it's all good
I love them she's not wearing black face
or anything right she's apparently not
yeah she close though she's [ __ ]
she's scratching the surface dude that
would offend you that doesn't offend me
what the point is why what is she hiding
in her hair though
I don't know that's the real that's the
real question yeah hey that is what what
could she be hiding what do you think
she's hiding in here the funny thing is
that doesn't have to necessarily be
Diana Ross it could just be like a silly
afro that [ __ ] is crazy right yeah I
would not think Daniel likes my soccer
all right what about Harry Hamlin as oh
we have to blur that what the heck Sid
Vicious why oh yeah you got the Nazis
[ __ ] on his chips yo
sit [ __ ] is a Nazi is he is he just
being like a Nazi is that no he's being
shade vicious in a mockumentary that Sid
Vicious was in in which he looked like
this oh so it's another layers deep
thing seems like someone just really
wants to wear a Nazi shirt yeah yeah
where do you get that from anyway you
get you go get that custom-made get it
yeah at the mall yeah
swastika tease.com
Nick just shows up with a shirt next
[ __ ] episode but then I'll be like no
but it's the Buddha sign it's the
Japanese because have you seen the
Japanese Buddhist yeah the one that's
tilted why's it gotta be Japanese
Buddhist has the same thing yeah
Hinduism as a swastika but there's like
four dots and because I only seen in
that mini style this one oh yeah so
these things are you okay with this one
I wish he didn't wear the leather jacket
oh because For Animals yeah it's more
offensive right I don't like that all
right how about this one Nikki Hilton as
a Native American is this all the same
[ __ ] party what is this I know it is
the same background dude it's all cost
Amigos barrels is that George Clooney's
party the background is the same it's
occupied
you said the background is the same yeah
that's what I'm saying it is
yeah it's [ __ ] George Clooney's
birthday party everybody's like wear
some you can get canceled Native
American costumes I think uh yeah that's
not that cool even you know it's a
little unfair when we were kids and we
were in school they would make us put
Native American [ __ ] on like during
Thanksgiving yeah we cut [ __ ] color
[ __ ] people we didn't know though but
we didn't know I got let me see if I can
find the photo of me um throw yours in
here yeah you got that [ __ ] on speed
dial what's up it's in my Instagram
somewhere I mean it's pretty popular to
do that I mean here's Ellie Goulding as
a Native American I bet the rest is
gonna be all like white women that's not
a costume that's Coachella
but you could also get that at the
[ __ ] Halloween now store you know
every you can still buy it as a ready
maker whatever the [ __ ] Halloween now
dude for sure you could buy these at the
store but they don't have that stuff
that's cool you should get that to
Halloween
costumes it's offensive to think that
these people don't know that they're
wearing something official you know what
I mean it's yeah it's like offensive
it's like insulting your intelligence
yeah it's like you know that you
shouldn't when like Nikki Hilton's
putting on [ __ ] Native American
headdress she had no point does it not
cross their mind that hey I probably
shouldn't do someone's gonna be mad hot
take though you think like Native
American like men out there are just
kind of like I ain't mad I know that
might not be fire if I see a white woman
or a black black woman or anyone in the
sorry I'm not thinking just taking my
people's dress I'm like you look fine as
[ __ ] right that's why I'm wondering you
know
I like Chinese dresses they accused me
okay my culture's not your prom dress
okay that's how I feel
like into a [ __ ] like evening gown
you'd be pissed it depends on issue fine
we're gonna [ __ ] roll right there
dude
shake hands and be like we'll see if
you're not a poser or not Nick's like
I'm Gonna Save you I think you'd be
pissed if you use a real black belt
oh that gets me so bad but she's from
Pasadena oh that's cool then oh even
more and she doesn't train with us oh
I'm gonna [ __ ] be pissed man all
right how about this one what the [ __ ]
Kenya more as oh another that's a that's
right I'm not really mad at that one
that's pretty full out huh Real
Housewives again that's probably yeah
what's up with that the damn everybody's
doing Hilary Duff as a pillow
Pilgrim in a Native American the rest is
going to be all Native American again
this is the [ __ ] they made us do his
kids I'm telling you if you're a serial
killer you can kill native trans people
if you're white and you don't want to
buy it does No One's Gonna no Native
American is going to be able to change
people doing this yeah that's the sad
part you know that's true No One's Gonna
Be able to do it like the next one's
native but also don't you guys want to
dress up as something else Cecil the
lion
now that's funny Cecil the lion
[Laughter]
she could have just said lion but she
wanted it to be this specific one that
was what I was gonna say do you think
she said this is Cease of the line or
someone saw this picture and like this
[ __ ] no she definitely wants to see so
the line that's like if you were dressed
as Donkey Kong it's almost like harambe
good will it be like that [ __ ] huh
that's a that's a good costume okay
oh
damn Justin Trudeau's ones oh Heidi Klum
as a Hindu god I smashed
all those arms look at all those hands
man I've been doing wild [ __ ] with those
hands different grips is this
infuriating I know I think that's a lot
of commitment
to go all blue you know that's [ __ ]
working and it actually looks pretty
cool yeah that's like a costume you know
what I mean it's not like a let me try
to look like a cute girl in this Native
American fit and still be you know but
at least the goddess it's like a figure
it's not a real yeah it's not a real
person that's a that's a already
quote-un-go fictional being it's like
yeah Hinduism Hindu gods belong to
everybody because we're all Hindu in
some way or another sorry to inform you
guys we just got the blessing hey FYI is
my outfit this year thank you Heidi for
spreading the word from here it looks
black and white I thought it was gonna
be Justin Trudeau with his tongue
sticking out
that was offensive but for so many other
reasons like bro this [ __ ] year 2000.
you went as Aladdin like nine years
after the film you know
[Laughter]
like in a Chinese culture like Monkey
King or something would that be the same
I don't know no because then you still
just look like a monkey you know what I
mean you're at the end of that you're
dressing up like an animal but if you
put a crown on your head then you Monkey
King baby like if I saw a white dude
dress like monkeying I'm not gonna be
offended and then if I saw him do like a
backflip I'd be impressed in class you
know what I mean like man I'll be hyped
so it's all about dedication to the
costumes yeah like I think that's what
it more is because it's like Heidi Klum
you can't even tell us Heidi Klum
it might really be colleagues like if
Heidi Klum came out and she's like I'm
Jet Li and she like shaved half her
forehead and braided the rest and stuff
like that and wore the [ __ ] outfit I
would still be like that's kind of
dedicated you gotta give her her roses
for that you know I think you gotta give
credit even though that's like a human
you know I mean I'd be like that's
dedicated like one year for Halloween I
was King Triton you know what I mean and
I [ __ ] looked just like him dog I
look just like the Quantic appropriation
I don't yeah when I smiled you can see
like oh that's a Chinese man that's not
a wife
oh you were King Triton I was gonna try
it did you look like just like a [ __ ]
old Chinese guy no no did you look like
pop skin over my body you know I mean
and it was all like buff and stuff you
just put on white skin all over your
body yeah but it was like it was like it
was like a costume listen to yourself
Nick yeah I'll put white skin on me
anytime I want dude I don't give a [ __ ]
got this for Halloween for Halloween
running errands and [ __ ] before I went
to work it feels like a school play yeah
yeah I was King Triton dude okay and I
was very I was very convincing people
get want to take pictures of me because
they were like oh my God you're such a
good contrite and my wife my wife was
Ariel did you have a merman flipper like
yeah yeah were you lying down sideways
all sexy like no I I had to flipper
though your wife was Ariel the daughter
the dog got it got it got it all right
all right let's lightning round the last
few of these I didn't know there were
any more left I thought that was like as
a Chic he wishes bro
but why aspiration yeah does he have
like Chic homies uh yeah it sure he does
he doesn't everybody oh shoes
to me I I see race after I see like you
know he's just execution he's just
flipping the script for himself today
you know what I'm saying he's just he
wants to be a woman right or is that
fact it's your sister bro
that's right a smart guy we're talking a
smart guy yeah
I'm not offended I'm still not offended
it's not that bad yeah wait wait wait
hold on go back guys Pat wants to say
something about behalf of Asian no not
on behalf Asian from my perspective it's
like all white people just do an
offensive action
so like I hear everybody I'm like sick
another one dude it's nice to see Tia
jump in the game all right here we go
Julian Huff is crazy eyes what's crazy
who's Julianna Dancing with the Stars
she's from she's supposed to be the
black chick from uh this crazy eyes I
think it's offensive to call her a
celebrity
is really enough I don't know sorry if
you're watching Julian you know she's a
big subscriber so she apologized
profusely for this one because she
actually did bronze her skin for that
who's crazy guys uh from oranges to do
black oh okay okay yeah and the actress
of that show that she's depicting is
black so and she does have crazy eyes
she has like walleyes which is great
yeah I think the line should be if you
paint your skin to be a different
color than yours then it's probably not
the right thing to do yeah yeah King
Triton unless it's blue unless it's not
a real human person say that to the
incestuous blue people somewhere in the
mid-americas yeah yeah how about this
one do you think this helps anybody why
do you want to be just straight up a
terrorist as a terrorist he couldn't
that's kind of funny what
can oh what it is
is that a bomb vest or something how's
it yeah I think he's got a bandolier
like is that around like the bullets
right now I mean that's that's his
normal [ __ ] ammo he probably has one
anyway I think he can get away with
anything these days Lily Allen is Dr
Luke so the reason this is offensive is
because Dr Luke the uh Mega producer was
uh accused of like sexually oh yeah
assaulting people huh well yeah like
he's like a he like out of the five main
music producers in the world he's like
he was number one oh [ __ ] really yeah so
she was like making fun of him she was
she was like making a pawn of his
costume but at the time that she did
that he was under allegations from other
uh artists that he had like sexually
like molested them so then they came
down on her about it so she is she just
spreading awareness I think she's just
she's just being [ __ ] badass and
doesn't give a [ __ ] and then you know is
Lily Allen a an artist yeah she got a
song called oh Kesha was the one saying
that oh this is the this is one of the
best ones ready
[Laughter]
if he just had a shirt that just like
said FBI and it was just the female body
inspector I feel like that's appears out
like he probably thinks he's like yo
this is [ __ ] hilarious oh my God
that's great classic dude what do you
think the [ __ ] what's he going for
here just a regular guy he's going for a
laugh bro he's going for a laugh he's
going for Laughs he's a hit he's a hit
at the point he's like hey I killed my
wife and I get [ __ ]
that's like literally what he's doing
people pay me to look at their [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]